public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
père laurent secrétaire national du
parti communiste français et sénateurs
est l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez vous donc de public sénat avec
la fp avec les échos et avec radio
classique trois grandes questions pour
les 45 minutes qui y viennent perdront
un emmanuel macron dément être un
président le président des riches est ce
qui vous a convaincu question que
viendra vous poser dans quelques minutes
et jean francis pécresse de comment
croyez vous possible le retour de
l'union de la gauche vous êtes cela à la
plaie encore aujourd'hui vous répondrez
sur ce sujet à lucile malandain enfin 3
est il trop tard pour sauver la planète
on évoquera bien sûr la coop 23 avec
orianne mancini mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
la quatrième journée de mobilisation
contre la loi travail confirmés tels
l'essoufflement du mouvement vous étiez
dans le cortège aujourd'hui à paris là
paris cortège clairsemé on peut le dire
partout en france est ce qu on a donc la
confirmation ce soir qu emmanuel macron
à le point comme l'avait dit un peu
dépité jean luc mélenchon moi je ne
crois pas du tout parce que là le bilan
de la séquence des six premiers mois et
singulièrement depuis la rentrée de
septembre c'est au contraire je pense qu
emmanuel macron a perdu beaucoup de
points dans l'opinion il était il avait
été élu président de la république et il
est aujourd'hui est aujourd'hui mis en
difficulté sur le soutien à sa politique
sur les ordonnances macron sur ce qui
est en train de se passer dans l'est
dans les communes dans les collectivités
locales où il ya une énorme inquiétude
et une énorme colère su après la
suppression des emplois aidés l'appel et
il ya une grosse réaction contre ça dont
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs est obligé de
tenir compte pour essayer de donner le
change on faveur des communes il perd
des points dans l'opinion mais gagne des
points en avançant sur les réformes et
là aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il a
neutralisé la rue par exemple il a ne
serait il alors ce pour le moment sur un
mode assez autoritaire en vérité parce
que il ne tient pas compte du tout de ce
qui se passe dans le pays il est en
train de s'enfoncer dans une impasse le
regarder ce qu'il est aujourd'hui donc
ces manifestations est-ce qu'elles ne
viennent pas confirmé ce qu'avait dit
laurent berger de la cfdt
les manifs ça sert à montrer notre
faiblesse
non mais il y à la manière de s'opposer
c'est les manifestations ça n'est pas
seulement ça c'est aussi qu'elle ne
voulait pas reconnaître que la bataille
est perdue
non d'abord elle n'est pas terminée
parce que la ratification parlementaire
des ordonnances va venir
et puis ensuite il faut transcrire il
faut passer justement aux négociations
de branche et là beaucoup de choses vont
se jouer là vous pensez que l'art
exemple que le combat doit se poursuivre
dans les entreprises comme le deal dans
les
crise aidant les bronches et dans les
bras dans les branches puisque
l'objectif des ordonnances et de vider
les accords de branche de leur contenu
pour renvoyer à des accords ou les
salariés seront en position défavorable
en fait le gouvernement défend dans les
branches notamment avec l'appui de
certains syndicats oui mais le
gouvernement évidemment on essaye de de
maquiller un peu ses objectifs mais je
pense que justement dans l'opinion
le message est clairement passé qu'il
était qu'il avait choisi son camp
finalement emmanuel macron et le message
qu'il est le président des riches
on va en parler est quelque chose qui
est quand même compris dans l'opinion je
propose de découvrir avec nous la
première question et sa réponse au
sondage opinionway réalisé spécialement
pour l'épreuve de vérité est il encore
possible de se poser aux ordonnances de
la loi travail et bien c'est non à 60%
oui à 38% donc oui je retiendrai je
retiendrai quand même les 40 % parce que
alors que le projet a été voté une
première fois l'assemblée même si je le
rappelle il ya encore la ratification
parlementaire des ordonnances il ya 40%
qui disent qu'il est encore possible de
s'opposer donc ça veut dire que c'est un
seul il y a malgré le matraquage qui
consiste à dire l'affairé réglée il ya
plus rien à discuter circulez ya rien à
voir
eh bien il ya beaucoup de gens qui au
contraire s'inquiètent de ce qui est en
train de se mettre en place et je pense
que ça va ça va continuer à grandir
parce que comme macron attaque un peu
sur tous les sujets en même temps un
avec des dégâts dans les services
publics on vient d'apprendre par exemple
qu'en matière d'audiovisuel public et
d'avenir des politiques culturelles il y
avait beaucoup de menace qui pesait sur
les budgets bien des notes qui circulent
sur des réductions de budget
des notes qui circulent pour dire qu'il
va falloir tailler drastiquement dans
les budgets publics de la culture mais
ça n'est pas le seul secteur où c'est le
cas alors en tous les cas vous appelez
toujours à la mobilisation évidemment ce
soir de manifestations mobilisations est
ce que l'alternative pour pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller chercher les
jeunes comme comme jean luc mélenchon
qui cherchent à investir les facs
mais il n'y a pas un succès pas besoin
d'aller chercher les jeunes les
étudiants sont assez grands pour
s'occuper eux-mêmes des problèmes qui
les préoccupent et je crois que là aussi
dans le sait qu'il ne vaut jennifer cité
non ils ne bougent pas souvent sous la
forme de manifestations mais je pense
que là la mise en place qui est en train
de se faire parce que c'est de cela dont
il s'agit
une sélection accrue à l'entrée de
l'université préoccupe beaucoup
d'étudiants qui déjà ont du mal à
trouver la filière de leur choix et je
pense que c'est une erreur profonde sur
l'avenir du pays
parce que si nous voulons hisser le pays
hors de la crise dans lequel ils se
trouvent
il faut au contraire parier à fond sur
la qualification des faits sur lui s'il
a réussi sur la réussite universitaire
c'est oui c'est sûr c'est qu'on va
réussir à jo sort bien sûr que le tirage
au sort est une est une solution est une
solution aberrante
mais je pense qu'on manque d'ambition
maintien de politiques universitaires on
manque par exemple de professeur des
écoles pour répondre aux défis de
l'éducation
on manque de médecins qui vont aller
dans les zones rurales qui manque de
médecins ou qui vont aller dans les
zones urbaines qui manque de médecins et
je pourrais multiplier les exemples dans
l'industrie on manque d'ingénieurs
qualifiés donc à beaucoup de secteurs où
on a besoin de parier sur la
qualification
la suite dé l'épreuve de vérité avec
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir jean france soir michel bonsoir
pierre laurent et le soir emmanuel
macron a annoncé une mobilisation
générale pour les villes pauvres
est ce que quand il dément être un
président des riches est ce qu'il vous
qu'est-ce qui vous convainc n'ont pour
le moment il ne convainc pas mais ce qui
se passe à propos des villes pauvres
enfin des villes de banlieue en
situation difficile et extrêmement
intéressant parce que emmanuel macron
n'a pas commencé comme ça il a commencé
par matraquer ses quartiers puisqu'il a
annoncé au cours de l'été la réduction
des dotations la mise en cause de
politiques de logement social la
suppression des dents des emplois aidés
et qu'est ce que ça a provoqué une levée
de boucliers chez les maires de ces
villes
et il ya eu ce qu'on appelle l'appel de
grigny dans une ville qui est dirigée
par un maire communiste
philippe riou qui a faim partie de cette
mobilisation pour dire stop pour dire ce
n'est plus possible la cote d'alerté est
dépassée et il ya une mobilisation et
elle a été transportée than deux maires
de toutes ces villes pour dire ça n'est
plus possible et le feu couvait est il
effectivement emmanuel macron ce qui
n'est plus possible c'est que les dents
sur les budgets de ces villes sont des
structures c'est ça que les budgets de
ces il s'en sort bien
la république n'y est plus présente les
services publics sont bons voilà et on
laisse ses quartiers à l'abandon on y
développe pas la formation
professionnelle on n'investit pas dans
l'éducation il ya des inégalités
terrible philippe riou a dit le maire de
grigny a eu cette formule ce que nous
demandons ce n'est pas un plan d'urgence
que nous demandons c'est que la
république revienne dans mon quartier
mais ses skis emmanuel macron dit aussi
lune alors d'ailleurs y voilà ce qui est
facile d'intéresser ambitionner ce qui
s'est passé d' intéressant c'est que
alors qu'il est parti comme je les dis
al'inverse de ça en coupant
drastiquement les vivres à ces villes en
particulier les plus pauvres ce qui
risquait de les mettre dans la faillite
il est obligé de revenir en arrière
parce qu'il ya eu cette mobilisation
bull ça n'est plus le président
il fait maintenant des déclarations
d'intention ouais que nous écoutons
un peu d'humour mais le problème c'est
que maintenant il faut que ça se
concrétise
parce qu'il fait des annonces
budgétaires et puis nous nous regardons
le projet de loi de finances que nous
sommes en train de voter
il n'y a pas de correspondance entre les
annonces budgétaires que fait emmanuel
macron et les lignes budgétaires qui
sont en phase donc nous allons puisque
là le débat a lieu à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat nous allons porter
les amendements qui sont demandés par
ces mères pour mettre en adéquation les
moyens maintenant à bonas des sentiments
déclaration d'intention votre demande
votre réponse c'est toujours plus
d'argent public
ce que dit emmanuel macron et d'autres
d'ailleurs c'est il faut faire autrement
on a déversé depuis des dizaines
d'années des milliards des dizaines de
milliards d'euros dans les quartiers sur
les villes nous renvoie les résultats
est ce que vous écoutez si vous allez
dans ces quartiers vous verrez tout de
suite et dans ses îles qu'on y déversent
pas comme vous dites des milliards pour
le moment les liens ou les déversent
dans les poches des actionnaires lors
les paradis fiscaux dans dans le cic or
on a mis 40 milliards dont le cic eux
sans que ça crée un emploi dans ses
quartiers dans ces villes à tous les cas
un autre ni amis les milliards
au mieux on y met des centaines de
millions au mieux
au mieux ça change la vie il a été très
bien accueilli j'ai vu la semaine
dernière en seine-saint-denis d'antan
que dans une ville qui avait bénéficié
effectivement de neufont important bien
sûr il avait choisi la ville avait été
choisi mais donc il y avait ce qui se
passe par exemple par exemple sur la
politique de la ville les décisions qui
ont été prises au coeur de l'été c'est
de couper les vivres de la politique de
la ville alors maintenant emmanuel
macron revient en arrière sur cela en
faisant des déclarations d'intention je
le répète qu'ils sont le résultat de la
pression et de la mobilisation comme
quoi c'est possible de faire bouger les
choses
seulement pour le moment derrière les
déclarations d'intention il n'y a pas
encore les les engagements financiers
nécessaires
est-ce que c'est oui donc pour répondre
clairement à pression oui dans ces
quartiers il faut deux il faut de la
présence publique
il faut des politiques publiques il faut
mettre de l'argent public par exemple
dans l'éducation dans la formation
professionnelle on va on va manuel
macron dit
10 milliards pour la formation
professionnelle et bien les maires en
question disent il faut en fléche et 2
milliards pour ces quartiers cet
engagement pour le moment n'est pas pris
alors on se parle donc là il s'agit pas
demandé de l'argent plus qui dit on va
mettre cet argent là l'analyse en nous
disant que mme affret enfin exemple oui
mais les emplois francs c'est une
décision qui est qui qui est mort né
quand elle a été annoncée il ya quelques
années mais n'a pas fonctionné mais sur
le talent qui est mort né ce qu'il faut
c'est des cds vrais emplois des emplois
qu'ils soient des emplois qu'ils soient
accompagnés de formation qu'ils soient
accompagnés de formation à propos des
emplois aidés nous ce que nous dit ce
sont des vrais emplois le dit lui même
s'ils ont les effets prix mais bien sûr
qu'il faut les transformer en emploi
stable mais il faut pas commencer par
les supprimer si on les remplace par
ailleurs du tout donc il faut les
maintenir dans un premier temps et il
faut des dispositifs d'investissements
massifs dans la formation
professionnelle et de l'emploi dans ces
quartiers est ce que cette idée de faire
appel à jean louis borloo pour mettre en
oeuvre ce plan pour les villes pauvres
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ce que
vous saluer son expérience d'homme de
terrain peut-être un borloo c'est pas la
plus mauvaise des idées que macro depuis
le début mais nous n'attendrons pas la
solution d'un homme miracle futile jean
louis borloo je le répète ce qui vient
de faire bouger les choses c'est que
plusieurs dizaines de maires se sont
unis pour dire stop
et pour commencer à mobiliser leur
population moi je pense que si demain il
n'y a pas cent mer mais il y en a 500
qui disent la même chose ensemble
ça sera bien plus efficace que seulement
la mission confiée à jean louis borloo
parce que nous voyons bien qu'il va
continuer à falloir faire pression parce
que l'argent dont on a besoin dans les
quartiers il va falloir aller le prendre
ailleurs donc il va falloir faire des
choix politiques
est ce qu'ils vont nous dit vous voulez
toujours plus d'argent nous n'avons dit
plutôt que d'en remettre à fonds perdus
dans le cic au ive au mieux les mettre
dans ces quartiers est ce qu'ils y font
pénaliser
l'évasion fiscale sur les jours ces
quartiers par exemple pour qu'elles
embauchent des jeunes issus de ces
quartiers qui ont assez souvent le même
niveau de diplôme que d'autres mais
qu'ils aiment et qu'ils sont
sa fusée à la porte sans que ça fait
partie de la destinée qui vont être
mises en oeuvre
ce qu'il faut des mesures plus
coercitives oui ça fait partie des
mesures qu'il faut prendre parce qu'il
faut que les politiques publiques comme
on dit dans le jargon un peu soi
territorialisées c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'elles s'adressent qu'il y ait des
dispositifs qui favorise en particulier
les quartiers les plus défavorisés parce
qu'il faut réduire les inégalités
mais c'est vrai dans le domaine de
l'emploi c'est vrai dans d'autres
domaines
par exemple je vous cite un autre
exemple ce qu'on parle beaucoup de sport
avec la coupe du monde de rugby légion
et bien dans ces quartiers il ya moins
de licenciés que dans la moyenne des
villes d'un même département
pourquoi parce que les clubs sportifs
sont trop pauvres parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à tenir on leur supprime
les emplois aidés on supprime les
subventions supprime la réserve
parlementaire où les asphyxie il faut
des politiques publiques pour développer
la pratique sportive dans ces quartiers
il faut de la gratuité
oui je pense que les associations sporta
exemple la licence dans un certain alors
ya des dispositifs publics qui existe
déjà pour aider les enfants à ce
licencié dans un club sans avoir à
débourser la somme il faut encourager
ces dispositifs où il par exemple on
vous avait parlé de la formation il ya
dans le plan dans le plan de réforme de
l'université qui a été présentée par
edouard philippe
il ya quelques semaines une coisy
sélection à l'entrée de l'université
mais qui vise aussi à faire en sorte que
des jeunes qui sont issus parfois qu'ils
n'ont pas tout à fait le niveau n'avait
pas échoué dans des universités dont on
considère qu'elles sont pas forcément
fait pour eux mais qu'elle aille plutôt
que ces jeunes aillent dans des voies
technologiques professionnels
est-ce que c'était ce que de ce point de
vue là si on met un petit peu de côté
cette idéologie autour de la sélection
d'université est ce que vous trouvez pas
que c'est une bonne approche
je pense qu'il ya trois il ya trois
problèmes et on les instrumentalise un
peu je pense qu'il ya un problème et
celui-là mon avis est maltraité ce qu'il
faut une plus grande ambition en matière
de l'université on a l'impression
s'alarmer du fait qu'il ya de plus en
plus d'étudiants je le disais tout à
l'heure moi je crois qu'il faut une
grande ambition pour l'université parce
que nous allons vers une société qui
aura besoin de qualification
donc on devrait pas avoir peur d'avoir
plus d'étudiants plus de campus
universitaires plus d'investissements
universitaire or pour le moment on a des
budgets qui ne sont pas à la auteur on a
auditionné ici au sénat il ya quelques
jours le président de la conférence des
présidents d'université il dit nous
n'arrivons pas à suivre la montée de la
démographie étudiante
deuxièmement il ya un problème de
réussite des étudiants effectivement et
oui il faut des dispositifs qui aide les
étudiants à réussir et il ya des
problèmes d'orientation
il ya des problèmes d'adéquation etc le
problème c'est qu'au lieu on dit on va
traiter ça en vérité certains essayent
d'instrumentaliser le problème pour
introduire de la sélection à
l'université je reviens à mon premier
point on n'a pas besoin de réduire le
nombre d'étudiants on a besoin au
contraire de l'augmenter donc tous les
dispositifs devraient être mis sur
l'aide à la réussite des étudiants
et effectivement il faut des mesures
nouvelles en la matière et nous ne
contestons pas le fait qu'il faut
travailler plus efficacement cette
question lors de son déplacement en
seine saint denis et puis dans le nord
pas de calais emmanuel macron n'a pas
repris son image des premiers de cordée
mais il a défendu l'idée que la réussite
des riches alimenter la prospérité de
tous et s'il disait vrai mais nous en
avons chaque jour la démonstration du
contraire puisque il y a deux plus en
plus de riches
les riches sont de plus en plus riches
et ça ne produit pas de la prospérité
pour le plus grand nombre
c'est vrai en france c'est vrai en
europe c'est vrai dans le monde
il suffit de lire les études que fait
chaque année régulièrement oxfam le rng
oxfam international qui montrent que
l'explosion des inégalités et la
concentration extrême de richesses
immenses dont quelques mains de grands
patrons multinationaux qui réussissent
merveilleusement
eh bien ça ne ruisselle pas comme disent
certains vers le plus grand nombre c'est
le contraire donc il y a un problème il
y a trop d'inégalités trop de richesses
concentrer trop de confiscation de ses
richesses
trop aussi de deux d'argent caché dans
les paradis fiscaux je le disais c'est
des sommes quand même considérable quand
on lui dit qu'on manque d'argent
donc nous ne croyons pas effectivement à
cette théorie
premier de cordée nous croyons que ce
qui tire le développement d'une société
c'est surtout dans les sociétés
d'aujourd'hui ou sommes formés on a
besoin de qualification
c'est le développement sur le
développement de tous et c'est là qu'il
faut mettre de l'argent
est-ce qu emmanuel macron est en train
de faire basculer le modèle social
français au fond vers un modèle social
plus anglo-saxon oui ça avec oman ça
avait commencé mais si on laisse faire
emmanuel macron on va vers des ruptures
en la matière je pense des ruptures
grave avec ce qui fonde est malgré tout
un tas de choses qui avait été attaqué
ce qu'on appelle le modèle social
français qui était un modèle qui visait
quand même un certain développement dont
l'égalité de la société il a dit là il a
dit c'est ce qu verture sociale il faut
ce qu'il faut pouvoir se la payer
en parlant de la collectivité de la
société dans son ensemble vous avez noté
cette phrase oui mais c'est là c'est la
preuve par exemple c'est la rupture avec
avec avec le modèle actuel parce que le
modèle actuel c'est un modèle de
solidarité entre ceux qui à un moment
donné sont dans la difficulté
soit parce qu'ils sont dans la maladie
soit parce qu'ils perdent leur emploi ou
est un modèle de solidarité inter
générationnelle ceux qui sont actifs
payent par leurs cotisations sociales
les retraites des plus anciens
c'est ce modèle qui fait justement la
solidarité de la société qu'on essaye de
mettre en pause et je pense que c'est
une très mauvaise chose
merci merci c'est un francis ricard est
un site de l'épreuve de vérité avec
lucile malandain de la fp l'épreuve de
vérité avec l'afp
bonsoir le sait michel bonsoir monsieur
laurent soir alors la question la
question croyez vous possible le retour
de l'union de la gauche
je crois qu'en tout cas il faut un
projet de gauche pour ce pays parce
qu'on nous a dit c'était la thèse d'
emmanuel macron on va être ni le droit
ni de gauche résultat on a la politique
la plus à droite qu'on ait jamais eu
donc je crois qu'il faut le retour d'une
politique de gauche et d'un projet de
gauche c'est-à-dire d'un projet qui
disent il faut le développement social
de tous dans la fraternité dans la
solidarité dans l'égalité et il faut que
ce projet se construisent en faisant
reculer le pouvoir actuel de la finance
parce qu'il ya de l'argent mais faut
l'utiliser autrement mais alors accepter
ça un projet de gauche finalement celle
au social le développement social de
tous contre le développement financier
de quelques puissants mais à l'heure
actuelle
à gauche on va bien que benoît hamon
monte son nouveau mouvement dans son
coin les écologistes aussi je ne parle
pas de la france a soumises de jean luc
mélenchon qui fait complètement bande à
part comment par exemple envisager des
choses des projets en commun je sais pas
je pense aux prochaines échéances
électorales comme les européennes en
2010 non je crois que ça va pas se
résoudre dans ma chance je crois que ça
va pas se résoudre du jour au lendemain
par le fait qu'on va tenter de mettre
autour de la table les anciens morceaux
de la gauche je ne crois pas que ça se
passera comme ça moi je pense qu'il faut
reconstruire par du projet et nous nous
mettons sur la table une proposition
nous proposons d'organiser nous allons
le faire une première fois au début de
l'année prochaine
des états généraux du progrès social on
veut nous faire renoncer à cette idée là
qui est une grande idée de la gauche eh
bien il faut faire des états généraux du
progrès social
il faudrait refaire entre nous tous des
assises pour l'écologie entre nous nous
allons dire nous allons ouvrir au
printemps qui alors nous les forces
sociales qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de gauche qui sont dans le pays
très nombreuses et puis ceux qui parmi
les formations politiques qui se
reconnaissent dans ces valeurs sont
prêtes à y travailler mais ça ne va pas
se passer que par l'eau c'est ça que je
veux dire il faut que ça se passe avec
les forces vives du pays les forces
sociales combat qui existent qui sont
nombreuses à gauche et qui justement ne
se reconnaissent pas dans cet état un
peu délabré des formes des forces de
gauche alors c'était le thème de notre
deuxième question du sondage opinion way
pensez vous qu'une union des formations
de gauche ps pcf france insoumise soit
possible 21% impossible 77%
il y a trop de différences entre ces
formations entre vos formations 77%
disent ça n'est pas possible
mais la réponse la réponse allait
compréhensible parce que qu'est ce que
constatent les gens c'est qu'il y avait
un parti socialiste qui était la
formation dominante à gauche qui a
complètement déserté et de manière
spectaculaire pendant le quinquennat de
françois hollande
les valeurs de la gauche et le projet de
gauche au point d'être représentés
pendant cinq ans par un premier ministre
manuel valls qui passait son temps à
attaquer lui la gauche et ses valeurs et
qui continuent d'ailleurs
restent donc les gens voient cette et
d'ailleurs ils ont sanctionné cette
situation donc maintenant effectivement
les gens d'ici je prends le littéral de
votre question entre le parti communiste
et la france insoumise qui ont critiqué
ce quinquennat et ceux qui l'ont portée
il va pas y avoir une union demain matin
et c'est évident encore manuel valls l
attaque des valeurs de gauche parce que
défend des valeurs
oui mais il soutient tous les jours il
soutient tous les jours un gouvernement
qui est en train de tourner le dos à ses
valeurs
il a porté lui même il a ouvert la voie
à cette politique par exemple avec la
loi avec la loi une connerie
donc évidemment ce n'est pas avec nous
elles valent ce combat reconstruire la
gauche par exemple
donc il va falloir la reconstruire qui
est posée parce que personne ne se
l'imaginent que vous allez reconstruire
et que vous posez non mais quand vous
posez la question comme ça c'est benoît
hamon parle bien sûr ancien salaire mais
quand vous posez la question c'est pour
ça je caumontais la réponse que vous
avez suscitée avec votre question les
gens quand vous leur posez la question
du ps pour le ps c'est ceux qui ont
gouverné manuellement les cinq dernières
années
oui mais bon ceux qui étaient avec lui
et il est prudent je mange si la série
degrassi on veut reconstruire la gauche
effectivement il faut et je crois je les
dis qu'il ya un projet possible à gauche
est nécessaire
eh bien il faut s'y prendre autrement il
faut repartir de ce que sont les valeurs
de gauche et qu'on soit dans les
conditions d'aujourd'hui un projet en
faisant des assises des états généraux
sur tel ou tel sujet et progressivement
nous allons nous allons y arriver parce
que des fois c'est pour jean luc
mélenchon a fait aussi en présentant un
programme pour la présidentielle par
exemple oui mais c'est aussi l'idée
d'avoir un projet il se trouve que vos
deux programmes sont certes ont certes
été publiés séparément mais qu'ils se
ressemblent s oui beaucoup
comment arriver à faire en sorte que les
gens qui peut-être comme vous dites sont
prêts à s'engager politiquement
comprenne qu'il existe deux formations
politiques différentes mais ç'a toujours
les mêmes idées et ça c'est toujours
quelque chose qui me surprend parce que
ça a toujours existé plusieurs
formations politiques et les français je
crois au contraire sont très attachés
mois à
le la pluralité politique retient
eux-mêmes tiennent beaucoup à la liberté
de leurs opinions
donc le fait qu'il y ait de la diversité
des parents soit un problème
ce qu'il faut c'est que ces forces de
gauche qui existent face dominé ce qui
les unit ce qui les rapproche
et puis continuer à débattre de leurs
différences mais en avançant ensemble et
moi c'est la méthode que je propose est
ce que le blues est possible est ce que
le blues ou la déprime de jean luc
mélenchon s'il on en croit une partie de
la presse vous donnent des ailes
en tout cas elle mais elle mais elle me
donne envie d'être plus offensif encore
pour construire ce que je viens de dire
à l'instant parce que je crois d'abord
que les idées communistes les idées que
nous portons avec notre parti ont
beaucoup d'actualité elle vous penser
qu'effectivement il ya une
démobilisation du côté de de la force
par exemple bah on voit bien qu'ils
réfléchissent à la manière dont ils vont
dont ils vont se positionner ils sont
partis très fleur au fusil
la fleur au fusil aujourd'hui seulement
et nous l'avons dit il va falloir
construire
voilà et peut-être avec l'idée que fort
des résultats qu'ils avaient obtenus aux
élections législatives il allait avait
tout seul résoudre le problème non il
faut il faut qu'ensemble nous
travaillons ensemble nous la france
insoumise benoît hamon et je le répète
beaucoup de citoyens qui sont
aujourd'hui un peu isolé mais qui sont
engagés ceux qui sont mobilisés dans le
mouvement associatif pour la défense du
logement social qui sont mobilisés sur
beaucoup de terrans ce moment se
reconnaissent aussi dans ces valeurs ne
sont pas forcément membre d'une de nos
organisations politiques
il faut donc créer des espaces qui leur
permettent de travailler ensemble
c'est ce que nous voulons faire avec les
états généraux du progrès le justement
le parti communiste entame sa révolution
vous vous réunissez dimanche la
conférence nationale avec son anglais
excusez moi avec tous les représentants
régionaux tous les tous les animateurs
des sections locales
il y aura plus de 900 participants et
et où un certain nombre de décisions
vont être vos entreprises notamment une
date pour le congrès il va donc y avoir
un congrès pour ça vous avez lancé une
consultation au moment de la fête de
l'humanité est ce que vous avez déjà des
résultats des remontées de cette
consultation
comment est-ce que vous
vous voyez les choses comment est-ce que
quelles sont les pistes pour réformer le
parti communiste pour le transformer et
oui vous allez faire votre évolution
vous confirmez oui je pense votre
révolution oui je pense qu'il faut que
nous aussi nous bougions beaucoup de
choses parce que il y à une aspiration à
la participation démocratique très fort
chez ceux qui veulent reconstruire la
gauche un parti communiste d'aujourd'hui
il faut que nous les associons c'est
pour ça que nous avons démarré le
processus de notre congrès différemment
d'habitude la direction publie un texte
on l'a on a décidé justement de
commencer par une consultation et vous
vous interdisez des mots non il ya
toujours eu de la démocratie mais on s'y
prend autrement pourquoi parce que déjà
il faut discuter il ya tellement de
choses à repenser à revoir il ya
beaucoup de travail à des défis énormes
on en a conscience
donc il faut un peu trier dans tout ça
par quoi on commence donc voilà des
questions qu'on a posés par sur quoi au
parc on commence alors on s'aperçoit
chez nous que par exemple les questions
de la révolution sociale mais aussi de
la lutte contre le coût du capital de
l'évasion fiscale est bien revient très
fort chez nous les questions l'écologie
viennent très fort on va en parler ce
qu'on va faire des assises communiste
pour l'écologie en 2018 avant notre
congrès pour le préparer à qik est très
très largement alimentée par jean luc
mélenchon oui mais tant mieux tant mieux
plus il ya de gens qui se mêlent des
grands sujets de la société moi ça ne me
pose pas de ça ne pose pas de problème
alors est ce que la vraie révolution du
parti communiste sera le jour où vous
abandonnerez le mot communiste non je ne
crois pas parce que la question qui nous
est posée sur le mot communisme ça n'est
pas celle là parce que nous croyons à
cette idée d'ailleurs l'idée du commun
qui est à la racine de notre engagement
est une idée qui reprend de la vigueur
singulièrement dans les jeunes
générations aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
des enjeux aussi écologique et tout le
monde voit bien qu'il faut plutôt
traiter les grands enjeux du monde comme
des biens communs plutôt que dans la
jungle de la concurrence donc nos idées
peuvent reprendre de l'espace mais
évidemment faut que nous soyons nous
identifier à ses idées modernes qui
les notes dans le xiième siècle non et
donc parfois il ya des il ya des ddd
chose du passé qui pèse lourd dans notre
image trop lourd dans notre image
donc on a besoin de modifier cette image
là mais elle ne signifie pas abandonner
le nom le nom communistes n'ont cessé
parement dans les consultations il est
est ce que vous aviez l'air d'être au
mieux on entend la question avant les jo
je serai bien ce qui vient très
fortement dans la consultation qu'on
fait c'est ne pas abandonner le mot
communisme mais travailler très
profondément sur notre image dans la
société vous avait fustigé manuel valls
il ya un instant il est intervenu avec
fracas d'une certaine manière est
récemment dans cette polémique ce
clivage violents entre charlie hebdo et
mediapart est ce que vous dites vous
toujours ce soir je suis charlie est ce
que vous dites plus que jamais m
à propos de cette polémique jeudi
surtout qu'il faut moi je crois à
arrêter apaiser cette polémique qui me
rend profondément triste parce que moi
j'ai des amis dont les deux rédactions
qui en ce moment s'affrontent de manière
très très pénibles et ça donne de
l'espace à des gens comme manuel valls
pour jeter de l'huile jeter de l'huile
sur le feu et diviser encore plus les
les gens qui pourraient construire
ensemble un projet de gauche
donc moi je dis un peu al ton feu dans
cette dans cette polémique qu'elle est
extrêmement dur quand vous sentez vous
justement c'est justement j'en pense que
la question actuellement telle qu'elle
est débattue et de manière très violente
de ce que je lis justement me paraît me
paraît très mal posé moi je pense qu'il
faudrait qu ensemble nous travaillons
sur et je crois que c'est possible
la défense la défense de la laïcité qui
est une grande valeur qui peut nous
réunir et puis la laïcité qui veut dire
aussi le respect des croyances des
religions
on donc le refus des amalgames et de
toutes les tentations islamophobes ou
anti musulmane qui existe et si ce qu'on
cultive et dans la société par certains
et en même temps le refus d idéologie
islamiste radicale une toute petite
question pour conclure le filmage une
toute petite question ça va être ça va
être à venir à vous je reviens un peu
sur le congrès est ce que vous est ce
que vous vous préparez à être quantité à
votre succession puisqu'il devait y
avoir un congrès devant la question va
se poser
écoutez je en tout cas là je suis
entièrement engagés dans la préparation
du congrès je ne pense pas que je
j'arrêterai j'arrêterai après le congrès
je viens d'être réélu sénateur
communiste de paris
donc j'ai plutôt le sentiment que j'ai
encore quelques belles années
d'engagement devant moi alors à quel
poste de responsabilité
si on fait le congrès en 2018 comme on
ferait on sait pas encore exactement à
quelle date ça va se décider
samedi il y aura un débat précis sur les
directions je pense qu'il faudra
remettre sur la table un peu la manière
aussi dont fonctionne notre direction
collective parce qu'on voit avec les
derniers élections qu'on est capable de
faire héberger beaucoup nouveau porte
parole
c'est vrai chez les sénateurs chez avec
des jeunes sénateurs qui ont été élus
c'est vrai à l'assemblée nationale et ça
nous fait du bien donc si j'étais si on
avait direction plus collective dans la
visibilité ce serait mieux en mai je
viens du jour je serai toujours là
raccord une espèce de bain de jouvence
mais qui vous fait du bien pour
continuer ses salles et des ah voila
merci
si vous voulez mais la cvo coulisses et
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant vous vouliez parler
d'écologie et d'environnement on y
arrive avec orianne mancini de public
sénat qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir oria saint michel on sort pierre
laurent bonsoir
emmanuel macron était en déplacement
hier à bonn à l'occasion de la coop 23
le seuil de l'irréversible a été
franchie ce sont ses mots
est il trop tard pour sauver la planète
selon vous c'est pas seulement les mots
d' emmanuel macron il a repris le
constat fait par les experts les experts
du giec qui ont lancé une deuxième
alerte quasiment enfin équivalente au
sens où ils ont dit c'est la deuxième
alerte après la première que nous avions
lancé et là il faut vraiment nous
écouter je pense qu'il n'est pas trop
tard mais ça veut dire et c'est ce que
disent les experts du giec que
maintenant il faut mettre les bouchées
doubles et il faut d'autant plus mettre
les bouchées doubles que des grands pays
du monde et singulièrement les états
unis avec donald trump sont en train de
faire machine arrière
donc il faut que la france et l'europe
eh bien nous poussions de manière
décuplé dans le sens d'une transition
écologique de tous nos modes de
production et de consommation et que
nous le fassions avec une très grande
vigueur et donc en y consacrant beaucoup
de moyens en tous les cas
emmanuel macron s'impliquent fortement
effectivement organe il a montré
beaucoup de volontarisme à bonn en
disant par exemple qu'il fallait se
substituer aux états unis pour le
financement du giec on l'écouté vous
réagissez je souhaite que le maximum
d'états européens puissent à nos côtés
justement tous ensemble compenser la
perte de financement américain mais je
peux vous garantir d'ores et déjà qu'à
partir de 2018 pas un centime ne
manquera au giec pour fonctionner
avancer et continuer à éclairer nos
décisions nous devons accélérer la mise
en oeuvre effective de l'accord de paris
alors enfin je lui donnais levé le poing
la wii sur cette décision là c'est à
dire de prendre le relais des états unis
pour continuer à ce que le gm fonctionne
c'est une bonne c'est une bonne annonce
des manuels macro maintenant ça c'est là
peut se dire est-ce et là c'est
important mais c'est la petite partie du
problème
la question c'est est ce qu'on va même
sur la table au plan de la france de
l'europe du monde les centaines de
milliards qu'il faut mettre pour
financer les transition écologique
nécessaire et c'est là pour le moment
que que le bât blesse par exemple
prenons des sujets concrets en france il
faut avancer maintenant un plan
d'envergure pour la transition
écologique de l'habitat et la transition
énergétique de l'habitat et pas
seulement dans les immeubles neufs avec
quelques programmes avancés
parce qu'il ya un énorme problème pour
revoir les la manière dont on consomme
trop d'énergie tout les passoires
énergétiques qu'on lit comme on dit que
ce sont de très nombreuses mais pour ça
il faut mettre des dispositifs
d'envergure sur la table et l'argent où
le trouver l'argent alors je jure cite
cet exemple mais il y en a d'autres
les paradis fiscaux quand est ce qu'on
va arrêter l'impunité des paradis
fiscaux
on estime qu' à 5000 milliards dans les
paradis fiscaux au plan mondial et on
nous dit on n'a pas l'argent pour mettre
100 milliards dont le fonds vert pour
l'écologie alors que la planète est en
train de brûler moi ça me scandalise
donc il faut effectivement par exemple
que la france 10 aux états européens
s'ils disent y'a un problème d'argent
établissons une vraie liste noire des
paradis fiscaux parce que les paradis
fiscaux ce n'est pas un problème
exotiques ils sont en europe aussi les
paradis fiscaux on a vu récit à 500
milliards dans les paradis fiscaux
européens
est-ce qu'on va aller chercher cet
argent pour le mettre sur la transition
et qu'on a bien entendu sur le nucléaire
pierre laurent et nicolas hulot a acté
le fait que la part du nucléaire ne
serait pas ramené à 50% en 2025 mais
plutôt en 2030
en 2035 est ce que c'est une bonne chose
selon vous écouter il a il a dit nicolas
hulot ce que nous nous avions dit dans
la transition écologique dans la dans le
débat excusez moi sur la loi de
transition énergétique
il a dit que si nous réduisions à toute
vitesse
la part du nucléaire et que nous
voulions maintenir les l'alimentation
énergétique de nos foyers nos
entreprises on allait être obligé
d'avoir recours aux énergies fossiles
c'est d'ailleurs
qui s'était passé en allemagne et nous
nous disions ça n'est pas raisonnable
puisqu'il faut précisément faire
exactement le contraire les experts du
giec 10 plus un centime dans les
énergies fossiles
donc nous si nous réduisons brutalement
la part de l'électricité nucléaire dans
notre mission d'engagement n'était pas
réaliste il n'était pas réaliste il
n'était pas raisonnable
donc nous nous sommes pour un mix
énergétique on nous présente toujours
comme les partisans du nucléaire donc
nous nous sommes nous avons toujours été
pour un mix énergétique diversifié dans
lequel il ya du nucléaire mais dans
lequel il faut maintenant faire monter
en puissance puis sens très rapidement
la production d'énergie redouble est-ce
que c'est quand même un échec pour
nicolas hulot est ce qu'il est le
ministre qui avale des couleuvres
non je crois que c'est enfin je voulais
fait confiance je le connais nicolas
hulot c'est la conviction et qui essaye
d'avancer qui a fait un choix un peu
personnellement ça ne vous étonnera pas
je trouve discutable de penser qu'il
pourra faire avancer ses dossiers dans
ce gouvernement là dont on voit qu'il
est ce gouvernement à ces prisonniers de
la pression des grands des grands lobbys
qui risque d'empêcher nicolas hulot de
faire ce qu'il a à faire mais en même
temps je crois je reconnais la sincérité
de nicolas hulot vous le souci et si
j'avais quelqu'un a critiqué dans le
gouvernement ça ne serait pas d'accord
nicolas lui paraît que emmanuel macron
c'est ce qu'on lit dans la presse en ce
moment dans le parisien également dans
paris match qui consacrent 18 pages
notamment des photos seins au président
de la république aujourd'hui ne l'ont
suivi pendant une semaine on lit dans la
presse que emmanuel caussé monsieur
tourbillon est ce que l'image juste
oui mais l'arrêt paris match pareil mais
tout ça oui y louer parce que vous savez
que j'ai un passé de journaliste donc
j'ai du mal à me passer
la lecture de la presse d'une manière
générale dont je je je sème les mélodies
je lis mon compte je lis beaucoup la
paille mais en l'occurrence parce qu'on
parlait de gâchis énergétique peut être
que 18 pages sur macron ça fait beaucoup
de papiers inutiles qui pourraient être
économisés non moi ce qui m'inquiète
dans tout ça c'est toute cette vie
politique qui ne cesse de tourner autour
de telles sommes alors donald trump
emmanuel macro je ne sais qui comme si
nous avions besoin dans un monde aussi
complexe que quelques un homme
providentiel nous sortent de la
situation actuelle je ne crois
absolument prochaines grandes réformes
que veut engager manuel macron c'est la
révision constitutionnelle la réforme du
parlement
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
limitation du nombre de mandats dans le
temps introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle est ce que vous allez la
soutenir cette réforme
tout ce que je vois d'abord je voudrais
dire une chose sur la réforme
constitutionnelle il faut arrêter les
discussions catimini qui par exemple se
mène en ce moment dans le bureau du
président larcher
c'est un groupe de travail sera mis
d'accord mais il faut faire très lent
mais c'est plus que ça ils sont en train
de chercher un compromis sans qui aucune
discussion publique entre le
gouvernement et la droite du sénat moi
je dis maintenant il faut mener ce débat
au grand jour faut que tout le monde
mette ses idées sur la table parce que
si on veut changer la constitution c'est
une question sérieuse que ne peuvent pas
régler quelques personnes et celle
pendant la réforme et la réforme le
chemin quel point nous inquiète parce
qu'elle vise à vider encore là le
maillage démocratique du préfet au
profit de la concentration toujours dans
l'est dans les hautes sphères de l'état
et je pense que c'est archaïque comme
vision de la république aujourd'hui au
21 est-ce que ça s'ils n'attaquent
contre le parlement
oui aussi on voit bien d'ailleurs on
veut encore réduire la discussion en
séance publique
on veut passer de plus en plus de texte
en commission on veut nous faire
travailler toujours plus vite en étant
moins nombreux bien sûr on veut priver
le parlement de pouvoir à propos de
parlements justement à propos parlement
le secrétaire d'état aux relations avec
le parlement christophe castaner prendra
samedi la tête de la république en
marche est-ce qu'il doit quitter selon
vous son poste de secrétaire d'état ou
par
oui je pense que ce serait mieux mais
bon après c'est les affaires se vous
êtes chef de parti est ce que pour vous
ce sont deux fonctions compatible d'être
secrétariat des dettes secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
c'est compliqué d'une corde j'ai dépensé
complet en veillant d'arbitrage je pense
je pense que c'est compliqué ne
serait-ce que du point de vue du temps
j'imagine donc ça dépend aussi on peut
pas être ça dépend du poste ministériel
qu'on a le plus simple serait de
probablement de distinguer les tâches
mais ça n'est pas obligatoire non plus
vous savez les fonctions ministérielles
sont des fonctions politiques aussi donc
il faut pas faire comme si tout ça était
des mondes qui s'ignoraient donc voilà
il faut respecter la tâche dans laquelle
on est moi je sais que j'en ai deux un
moment donné j'ai eu un petit période de
jeu chevauchée avec une autre fonction
élective je me suis aperçu qu
effectivement le cumul des mandats c'est
ça a ses limites
donc j'ai une fonction politique une
fonction par un parlementaire
voilà on a peu parlé finalement que jean
luc mélenchon dans cette émission vous
avez noté perdre on en parle dans la
presse aujourd'hui
il a déminé sur son blog des révélations
à venir sur son patrimoine vous avez vu
un des papiers qui sont annoncées dans
la capitale et dans l'express ça vous
fait réagir
non parce que je te connais rien de cela
et en plus cette manière de mener le
débat politique à coude affaires
successives
moi ça me donne plutôt la nausée donc en
valent pas d'affaires là on parle de
nantes oui mais de révélations de
pseudo-révélations je ne connais rien au
dossier en question
donc voilà ça fait quand vous regardez
ça m'intéresse assez peu je préfère je
préfère mille fois parler de ceux de ce
dont on a parlé sur l'écologie ont fermé
non sur l affaire on verra ce qu'il en
est mais jean-luc mélenchon dit qu'il
est victime de l'égout médiatique c'est
votre sentiment
il est souvent il est souvent attaqué et
en même temps il est souvent présent
dans les médias on va dire que c'est
laid que c'est les deux d'ailleurs quand
vous invitez pierre laurent on n'est pas
obligé de passer du temps sur jean luc
mélenchon ou sur un nom et un autre
dirigeant politique autant consacrer le
temps disponible à la parole de 2,2
l'invité c'est ce que vous faites avec
tout le monde il faut le faire et quand
j'aurai avec vous sur 45 minutes car à
44 une dernière sociaux est quasi morte
quand même très dur sur les médias vous
les condamnez vous avez rappelé que vous
étiez mais je n'ai je constate tous les
jours que ça n'a pas l'air de déranger
extrêmement les médias puisqu'il est
très souvent invité par les médias dont
visiblement les médias les médias aiment
ça je pense ce genre de polémique
merci à vous merci oria merci merci à 12
morts soir à bientôt
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]